- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about how you can be authentic.
Rule #4 is our personal favorite,
and I hope you stick
around to the very end
for some special bonus clips,
as well as my take,
and as always, if somebody says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat happy music)
- Be authentic.
Be authentic.
Many people don't even
know what that means.
It means that you're
clear about who you are.
You're clear about your
purpose, your protocols,
and your plans.
You're clear about what you're up to,
and you speak the truth
of that all the time.
Be authentic means you're in integrity,
that what you think, what
you say, what you feel,
and what you do, all matter.
Now, I know that's hard in Washington,
(laughter)
because there's just some
truths you can't tell out here,
but we want to do the best that we can,
and when you can't, pray about it.
But be authentic.
So many of us don't allow people
to know who we are.
As I travel around this country,
I meet people all over the country
who are suffering in silence
because they're not authentic about
what they need, what they want,
what they're doing, what
they're experiencing.
- Every decision we make in our lives,
as individuals, or as organizations,
is a piece of communication.
It's our way of saying
something about who we are,
and what we believe.
This is why authenticity matters.
This is why you have to
say and do the things
you actually believe
because the things you
say and do are symbols
of who you are,
and we look for those symbols
so we can find people who
believe what we believe.
Our very survival depends on it,
so if you're putting out false symbols,
you will attract people to those symbols,
but you won't be able
to form trust with them.
This is what Tiger Woods did to us.
He lied.
He told us what he thought
that we wanted to hear,
and it was great, and we were drawn to it,
and all of us who kind of liked that idea
of sort of the good guy
were drawn to it,
until we found out it was a lie.
He could have been the bad boy of golf.
He could have had all
the same endorsements,
and had a fantastic career,
and still been hailed as one of the great
athletes of our day,
but he didn't.
He chose to lie.
Good luck forming trust again, Tiger.
We don't believe you.
We don't trust you.
The goal of putting something out there,
if you say what you believe,
and you do what you believe,
you will attract people who
believe what you believe.
If you go to one of your friends,
and you say to one of your friends,
"How would you like me to dress"
"so that you'll like me better?"
"How would you want me to address you?"
"How do you want me to speak
so that you'll like me more?"
Right?
You're friends are going
to look at you and be like,
"What are you talking about?"
"Come on, come on, come
on, what should I wear"
"so that you'll find me more appealing,"
"and how would you like
me to speak to you,"
"so that you'll like me more?"
Your friends are going to tell you,
"Just be yourself."
"That's why I like you."
"I don't care ..."
"Just be yourself."
Now think about what we do in industry.
What do we do?
We do market research,
and we go out and we ask the customers,
"What kind of things, the way we ..."
"What style should we speak to you?"
"How should we decorate ourselves?"
"What kind of things are you drawn to"
"so that we can do those
things so you'll like us more."
It's just as ridiculous.
Organizations should say and do the things
they actually believe,
and they will attract people
who believe what they believe,
or they can choose to lie,
and at the slightest hint
that they might be lying,
cynicism sets in,
and people start saying, "I'm not sure"
"I can trust these guys"
"because there's not a lot of consistency"
"in all the things they say and do"
"which means they can't have
a very strong belief set,"
"or they're lying to me."
We call them inauthentic.
The entire process of asking other people
who we should be is inauthentic.
That's hilarious to me.
All these positioning studies
we do are inherent ...
"We're going to do a study
to find out from people"
"so we can be more authentic."
That's hilarious.
(audience laughing)
Say and do what you actually believe
and the symbols you put out there,
the things you say and the things you do,
those red hats, are ways
that people can find you.
- Are you always editing your life?
Look, that bird is singing up there,
(bird noises)
Right?
It's not editing its
life, it's just doing it.
There is no stop button in life.
There is no rewind button in life.
If you fall down, well, you fall down.
You got to get back up.
You can't say, "Cut."
"Let's do that again."
It happened.
There is no rehearsal,
so on a practical level,
I remind myself that I
don't have to use a filter
every time I post a selfie.
How I am, surely, is good enough.
Once I reminded myself of that,
I started to live a more authentic life.
Less editing,
more improvising,
more being in the here and now.
- To be authentic,
we have to be super, super present
and aware in every
conversation that we have,
so I encourage you next time you go out
to a lunch or a dinner with your friends,
put your cell phone
down, and actually listen
because that's what a
highly authentic person
would do is just to be
fully present in the moment.
The highly authentic person
is truly retrospective,
and what I mean by that is they're always
looking back at the week,
they're always looking back two weeks,
and they're seeing lessons
that they've learned.
They're journaling.
They're really trying to
understand what happened,
and how to make it better
in the present moment.
They're not looking back
from a painful sense,
you know, the pain body,
as Eckhart Tolle would talk about,
but they're looking back at it
from a sense of what can I
learn from this experience,
so that they can transcend
that vicious circle,
that monkey mind, or whatever they're in,
and lead to a higher
level in their own life.
The reason for doing this is often
to impact other people.
- Greatness is not this
wonderful, esoteric, elusive,
God-like feature that
only the special among us
will ever taste, you know.
It's something that truly
exists in all of us.
It's very simple.
This is what I believe,
and I'm willing to die for it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Period.
It's that simple.
- I know who I am and
I know what I believe.
- I know who I am, I know what I believe.
- That's all I need to know.
- And that's all I need to know,
so from there, you do what you need to do.
- You don't need everyone to like you,
and in fact, it's not even possible
to make everyone like you,
even if you do everything perfectly,
so you have to just
accept that certain people
will not like you, and that
it doesn't really matter.
In fact, your best strategy
and chances at success in life,
chances at fulfillment,
and chances at the most people liking you
is to be yourself
because when you're yourself,
your authentic self,
you're magnetic.
You're attractive.
People want to be near you,
maybe not the same people
that want to be near
your fake self right now,
so acknowledge that.
I'm not saying that you
can maintain everything
in your life as it is,
and still be yourself.
You might need to make some sacrifices.
There might be some costs
because chances are, right now,
you've whored yourself out,
and now you have some social debts, right?
When I tell you to stop
caring about other people,
and start being authentic,
well, you're going to come
up with all sorts of reasons
about why that's too costly for you.
You're going to say, "Well,
then my boss will say"
"something bad."
"My job might be in danger."
"My relationship might be in danger."
"Somebody else might be in danger."
Well, what's more important to you?
Is it more important for you
to be getting those shallow things,
or is it more important for
you to be self-expressive,
to really be yourself, to
really be fulfilled inside,
and then, to act from that,
and to live your life from that,
and to create a business from that place,
to create a career from that place,
to create a nice
relationship from that place?
What's more important?
I mean, you can still
keep whoring yourself out
if you want to,
but in the end, being a
whore is not a good way
to go through life,
so my suggestion is to bite
the bullet on this one,
and be yourself despite the costs.
In fact, what I'll have you do is ...
We're going to wrap with
this, something practical.
I want you to write down
a list of all the ways,
and all the areas in your life,
where if you started
to really act yourself,
really honest with yourself,
and expressing yourself honestly,
where you might incur some costs,
where there might be some
friction and some tension.
What are those debts that
you're now kind of sunk into?
I want you to write those down,
at work, in your relationship,
you know, in any kind of
interaction you're having
with other people,
any area of life.
Write them down.
Maybe you think that you'll
have strain in your marriage.
Maybe you'll think you'll
have strain at work,
so write those down,
and be specific about what the costs are,
and then, when you survey
the whole list of costs,
I want you to say,
"Am I satisfied with these costs,"
"or am I going to decide
to be my authentic self"
"despite the costs?"
Fuck the costs.
Be yourself.
You're going to be much happier,
and, ultimately, you're going
to be more successful too.
It just might take a while for you
to recreate your life a little bit
because some of those things
might actually fall off ...
You know, out of your life,
and when they do, you
have to be okay with it
because you have to recognize that
when you are your authentic self,
now people ...
It's going to be better.
It's going to be more of a stable success
because now people that are
going to be attracted to you,
and situations that you're
going to be involved in,
those are going to be more authentic.
They're going to be
aligned with you, right,
rather than being the sham
that they are right now,
so you got to stop living
this sham kind of life.
The final exercise that
I'm going to wrap on,
is the following.
I want you to observe
yourself over the next day.
In very subtle ways,
I want to you to see how
you're whoring yourself out,
and I want you to call yourself out on it.
For example, if someone sends you
a simple little email,
and you want to reply to it,
but then, all of the sudden
you kind of stop yourself,
and your natural reply,
you want to kind of a,
you know, you want to
soften the edges of it.
You don't want to be
coming off too impolite,
or too rude, or you're worried about
what that other person is going to,
how he's going to interpret your response,
and you kind of dumb down your response
on that email,
make it kind of sweet and polite.
Well, notice that.
Notice what you're doing there
is that you are whoring yourself out
to get a positive
reaction from that person.
At that point, I don't
want you to judge yourself.
This is kind of mindfulness.
I also have a video on
mindfulness you want to check out.
This is practicing mindfulness
is you just observe yourself
whoring yourself out,
and you don't judge yourself.
You don't say this is bad or good,
you just let it be,
and you just follow through.
Carry it through.
Whore yourself out,
but be conscious.
This time, do it consciously,
and I want you to do
that for the whole day,
and notice the subtle little
ways in which you're doing it.
- So my take on this is
if you want to be authentic,
then you have to understand
that you are unique.
You have something special.
You have a gift.
You have a voice.
You have something that is
different and special and unique
about you and it's okay,
and that's a good thing.
I think too many people
are trying to fit in.
Too many people worry about
what other people think
about them.
Too many people are trying
to live a life according
to other people's expectations
instead of their own.
You have your own voice,
and in order to be authentic,
before even worrying about
being authentic for others,
you need to be authentic to yourself,
and learning to listen
to that little voice,
learning to trust that little voice,
learning that when you
have this crazy idea
for something that you
want to try or do or say,
that you do it,
even in some small way.
You let go of the fear.
You let go of the fear of failure.
You let go of the fear of judgement.
Let go of any fears
that you have around it,
and just go out and do something about it.
The more you get used to trusting
that little voice inside your head,
the more you get used to
when you get that idea,
actually doing something about it,
then you'll start to live
a much more authentic life
instead of a cookie cutter life version
that somebody else has created for you.
So I believe that it starts with you.
It starts by trusting yourself more.
It starts by saying yes to things more.
It starts by not bowing down to fear more.
You need to be authentic
to yourself first.
From there, it's having the courage
to be authentic in every situation.
There was this really great clip
of Warren Buffett and Jay Z,
they're being interviewed
by Forbes magazine,
and they asked Jay Z if
he's ever intimidated
when he walks into these
business boardrooms
because that wasn't how he grew up,
and he said something like--
- This is who I am, you know.
This is what I do.
- What I always feel that
I liked about that clip is
here is a guy who is unafraid
to always be himself,
even when he's in a room
that he may not have ever been in before.
How many times are you in a situation
that you've never been in before,
and you have the pressure
to act according to
the rules instead of acting according
to how you wanted to act?
I think the more confident
that you are in yourself,
the more authentic you believe you are
to yourself,
then the easier it is to
express that outwards.
When you have full confidence in yourself
with who you are and what you want to do,
then, suddenly, other people's opinions,
they don't matter as much.
When you don't know what you do,
when you are afraid,
when you don't have that
level of self-awareness
and self-confidence, and
finding your one word
can really help you in that,
then that's when you get
ruled by other people,
and that's when you are afraid,
and that's when you say no to things
that could be really helpful to you.
That's when you don't
take those opportunities
that you should.
Those are my suggestions,
and I'm really curious to
figure out what you guys think.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know,
what challenges do you
have in being authentic.
Please leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I made this episode of Believe Life
because Dax Miller asked me to,
so if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next Believe Life,
please leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of the clips
resonated the most with you and why?
What did you take from this video
that you're going to apply to
your life or your business?
Please leave it in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Christophe Logiste.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
and for tweeting that awesome picture out.
I really, really appreciate it, man.
Thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- I think over time, people
develop their own signature,
and I think it takes a while to find out
what your signature really is.
I'll fast forward a little bit.
Where I am now, we never
really marketed ourselves.
As I began to build a little company
around the success of the book,
and I brought in other
trainers and coaches
and presenters,
and started to build
some product around that.
Still not a huge company.
I mean, there are only 20 plus of us,
you know, doing that work,
but we're partnering with
other people out there,
but as I started to do that,
we really realized that the
brand had kind of run out
from under us.
GTD, which was the shorthand
for Getting Things Done
became this global thing, kind
of like Kleenex and Xerox,
and we didn't own it.
I mean, we owned it, but
it was kind of running
faster than us, and we
really had to rethink
how are we showing up
out there in the world
because people would meet me, or meet us
and go, "Wow, you're nothing
like what I expected"
"you to be."
I said, "What did you expect me to be?"
They said, "Well,
corporate and left-brain"
"and hard-working and
rigorous and disciplined"
"and whatever," and a lot of people go,
"You know, I probably
should but that's not me."
Well, that's not us either,
and so, there was a
disconnect between how we were
actually showing up in the world,
and people's perception
of us and the reality.
We had a really smart guy
help us think through this,
and it's really about being authentic.
Those really tie together called
what's my signature?
What's the David Allen signature?
If you go to my website now,
if anybody ever saw it a year or two ago,
it looks very different
now than it did then
because what we decided was,
look, take the tie off,
(laughs) you know, because I'm really
kind of a hang out, spontaneous, you know,
kind of guy which is really a lot
of what my methodology's about
and what the message is about.
Initially, we had targeted the market
of the people, those are the people,
the high-profile professionals
and fast-track professionals were the ones
who were probably in the most pain
in terms of overwhelm,
and they could use the
methodology the most
to begin with, but the truth is,
it's for anybody.
It's now spread around the world,
and our signature,
in other words, our expression
is much more aligned
with who we really are.
We really didn't have to go anywhere.
You know, many times the
problem companies have
is their marketing is a big ta-da,
and they can't deliver on the big ta-da.
Well, our ta-da sucked.
You know, we were delivering huge value,
and people were having
transformational experiences,
but you know, it didn't
look that way, you know.
So we said there are a lot
of people we're not reaching
because there's kind
of an inauthentic-ness
about what we were doing.
So we--
- [Interviewer] That's been aligned now,
with the new website and the new brand?
- Yeah, yeah, much more so.
Whether it works as a
business, I don't know,
but it's certainly a
lot more fun (laughs).
- [Interviewer] Okay, that totally
makes sense.
- I don't have to show up
and try to be somebody else,
or have to deal with
people's perception of me
not being who I really am,
so it may be more approachable,
lowering the bar for people
to be able to engage,
and to engage with me.
You know, early on, you have to kind of,
you know, everybody, you know, probably
gets a nice business card
so that you look like you're bigger
than you probably really are.
You know, you start to
create an image and a brand
around who we think we really ought to be
given so we can attract people,
and not turn them off,
but at some point, you
really need to kind of
catch up with that,
and allow yourself to just
kind of be who you are,
and let the world come to you
that are interested in you.
- [Interviewer] Okay, makes sense.
- But that's been as much
a personal development development,
as a marketing development on my side.
- [Interviewer] Okay, that's fascinating,
so, again, there's two
things happening here.
As you develop in the
personal development,
the marketing, those
two things are aligned,
and they're important for them both
to create a successful business.
- I think so.
You know, but I'm not ...
I haven't studied all
the successful businesses
to say that's how they did it.
I do know that in the
world that we're in now
because it's so transparent,
and social media can
spread word like crazy,
and essentially that transparency,
the more authentic you are,
probably, the safer it's going to be,
so you don't have to, you know, worry
about trying to be
something that you're not,
or, "Gee, they thought of me as that,"
"and now, I have to be that for them,"
"and I have to be that for them--"
- [Interviewer] It just makes life easier.
- It does make life easier.
Whether it makes it
more profitable or not,
I would think so,
but I, you know, I think the world
gets attracted to authenticity.
- [Interviewer] I agree.
- That's, I think, where the world is
because it's so transparent,
in-authenticity, I think, shows up,
at least subliminally if not directly.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know, so, you know,
people out there are trying
to create marketing campaigns
that really aren't who you are,
are trying to show up as something
that's just somebody's writing ad copy,
but then, your engagement
with the company,
you know, doesn't hold up to that,
or doesn't match to that,
you know, that's tricky business.
- Competition is one of the
greatest illusions ever created,
but more so, something which keeps us
out of our true authenticity.
If I say I want to compete with you,
compete with what,
because you were born at
a different time than me,
you've got a different objective than me,
and we aren't in the same time and space.
(inhales)
Instead of competition,
think more of cooperation.
That helps you become more authentic
because you say, "I get it."
"You are totally unique and weird,"
"and guess what?"
"I am totally unique and weird,"
"and now, we don't have
to go against each other."
"We can work together,
and honor our uniqueness,"
and then, you just (inhales), mellow out.
- Self-Love is absolutely vital
when being authentic,
so it's taking the
shadow, the flaws of you,
of that person that you are,
and meshing it together with
that infinite intelligence,
that centered-ness, that connected-ness,
that compassion, that love,
that light that you are,
and going out into the world
and demonstrating that.
It's all about the demonstration,
and as you demonstrate more, my friend,
the more people are
going to come up to you.
They're going to see you as a catalyst
for change in their own life,
and you never know who
you're going to impact,
but you've heard me talk about it before.
It's that ripple effect,
so the more you and I
can become authentic,
we can become in that state of flow,
that state of awesomeness,
we could call it,
or that state of truly being authentic,
everything else will change in your world.
People are going to come
to you out of the woodwork
asking you how you did it,
and that's when you can show them
how to be truly authentic,
and really benefit and change their life,
and that's what it's all about.